People ask me often about how to conduct themselves in a Japanese business meeting.
First thing is the bow or shake question.
You know, bowing is very important and you should definitely learn how to bow sincerely in Japan...
...but often Japanese businessmen want to shake your hand, of course.
But bowing for them is second nature so they might bow and shake at the same time.
Be flexible.
Bow, shake, do whatever your counterpart wants you to do.
But then, when you sit down, pay attention because you will be directed to a proper seat.
There's a proper seat for everyone in a Japanese business meeting:...
...according to position and whether you're the host or the guest.
So look and you'll be guided, take your proper seat.
And of course, business cards are always important.
You get a business card, you study it.
You don't just put it away.
Give yours graciously.
Take the one from your counterpart and study it.
Take note of his position.
Even make conversation out of it if you can.
Finally, giving and receiving gifts.
Gifts are great, Japanese people like to present you with something...
...and it will be really good for you to have something.
Any little gift is appreciated and it shows you understand Japanese customs.